während die einen immer lauter vor der
drohnenkatastrophe warnen behaupten die
anderen das wäre alles hysterische
Panikmache zum Vergleich verweisen Sie
gern auf die aufgeheizte Debatte um das
Waldsterben in den 1980er Jahren damals
hielten viele Menschen den Tod der
Wälder für unausweichlich heute 40 Jahre
später sind die Wälder aber immer noch
da waren die Warnungen also reine
Hysterie die Maßnahmen eine
Panikreaktion oder steckt hinter der
ganzen Geschichte vielleicht doch mehr
genau das haben wir uns genauer
angeguckt first Experten aus ganz Europa
gehen München der Frage nach hat der
Wald noch eine Zukunft Fichten Kiefern
Buchen und Eichen werden Opfer des
Klimawandels und dabei sollten Sie das
Klima eigentlich als grüne Lunge
Schützen holzbäume in saftigen grünen
standen gibt es oft nur noch totes Holz
eindrückliches und auch bedrückendes
Zeichen dafür dass Auswirkungen des
Klimawandels längst auch in unseren
Breiten wirken
Bäume reinigen unser Regenwasser und die
Luft erzeugen Sauerstoff und kühlen im
Sommer die Städte außerdem verhindern
sie Erdrutsche und Bodenerosionen und
sind als Forster auch ein wichtiger
Wirtschaftsfaktor deswegen war der
Schrecken groß als sich der Zustand der
Wälder in den 70er Jahren immer weiter
verschlechterte erst zeigten Nadelbäume
schwere Schäden in den 80er Jahren dann
auch Laubbäume die Nadeln und Blätter
wurden braun und vielen ab die Kronen
vernichteten sich ein schauriger Anblick
verantwortlich machte man dafür den
sauren Regen der entstand hauptsächlich
durch die Verbrennung fossiler
Brennstoffe im Industrieanlagen
Heizungen und Autos denn in fossilen
Brennstoffen finden sich neben
Kohlenstoff der zu kohlenoxiden
verbrennt auch Schwefel und Stickstoff
die zu schwefloxiden und Stickoxiden
verbrennen
diese Stoffe schädigen die Bäume direkt
oder lösen sich im Wasser der Wolken das
Wasser versauert und wir bekommen sauren
Regen mit einem pH-Wert unter 5,6 und
auch heute ist unsere Umwelt durch die
Nutzung fossiler Brennstoffe stark
gefährdet und wir müssen dringend CO2
einsparen wie die App Klima euch dabei
unterstützen kann darauf gehe ich am
Ende des Videos noch mal genauer ein
also bleibt gerne bis zum Ende dran
durch den sauren Regen versauerten die
Böden und das wiederum war gar nicht gut
für die Pflanzen die Wurzeln wurden
geschädigt die Bäume erlitten
Mangelerscheinungen und
aluminiumvergiftungen auch für Schäden
an den Blättern und Nadeln der Bäume
wurde in den 80er Jahren noch der saure
Regen verantwortlich gemacht der Befund
dass der saure Regen unseren Wäldern
schadet geht auf eine Studie von
Forstwissenschaftler Prof dr Bernhard
Ullrich zurück veröffentlicht 1979 ja
sagte damals voraus dass große
Waldflächen in Deutschland
unwiederbringlich verloren gehen würden
mit einer SPIEGEL-Titel Story im
November 198 80 begannen zwei Jahrzehnte
in denen man immer wieder vom sauren
Regen und seinen katastrophalen Folgen
für den Wald hörte
Umweltorganisationen warnten die Medien
griffen die Botschaft auf und
dramatisierten sie weiter ein Ende des
Waldsterbens in der Bundesrepublik ist
nicht in Sicht auch der Wahlkampf trug
dazu bei vielleicht wegen der
Bundestagswahl erreichte die Debatte
ihren Höhepunkt schon 1983 ein Jahr
bevor die Waldschäden ihren Höhepunkt
erreichten die Botschaft kam auch bei
der Bevölkerung an die meisten die
damals die Nachrichten verfolgten
erinnern sich noch daran jedenfalls wenn
man sie darauf anspricht denn in den
letzten 20 Jahren war es verhältnismäßig
still um sauren Regen und das
Waldsterben wenn man sie heute an das
Waldsterben der 80er Jahre erinnert ist
ihre Reaktion oft oh ja ja da war ja was
und dann schauen sie aus dem Fenster und
sehen der Wald ist noch da
die Katastrophe ist wohl ausgeblieben
waren also auch die Warnungen
übertriebene Panikmache
was ist wirklich passiert
bis zum Jahr 2000 sollte die Katastrophe
kommen bis dahin sollte es keinen Wald
mehr in Deutschland geben das haben
viele gedacht aber die Katastrophe kamen
nicht warum nun zum einen waren nicht
alle Wälder gleichermaßen betroffen
manche Baumarten vertragen saure Böden
besser als andere und manche Böden
können Säure besser neutralisieren als
andere vor allem kalkhaltige Böden
versauern nicht so schnell Bernhard
Ullrich das war der mit der Studie am
Anfang war eine der lautesten Stimmen
vom Waldsterben das alle Wälder
absterben würden hat Ulrich aber nie
behauptet in den nächsten Jahren werden
flächenhaft Waldbestände absterben das
ist das was ich gesagt habe und das war
auch so im Erzgebirge im Harz oder im
Bayerischen Wald überall dort wo die
Wolken in die Kronen eingedrungen sind
war die Belastung stark das hatten wir
seit Mitte der 60er Jahre
wissenschaftlich untersucht dass die
öffentliche Debatte so dramatisch wurde
dafür Ulrich die Schuld den Medien
anfangs hatte er zwar selbst noch gesagt
dass große Waldgebiete nicht zu retten
wären damals dachte er aber auch noch
dass nichts gegen die Luftverschmutzung
getan werden würde dann kam es aber
anders in den 80er und 90er Jahren
wurden effektive Maßnahmen zur
Verbesserung der Luft Wasser und
Bodenqualität umgesetzt in Deutschland
wurden Luftfilter in Industrieanlagen
und Katalysatoren für Autos
vorgeschrieben und Schadstoffgrenzwerte
eingeführt dadurch reduzierten sich die
SO2-Emissionen in den 90ern um etwa 88
Prozent
Stickoxid-Emissionen immerhin um etwa 33
Prozent und bis heute sinken diese Werte
übrigens alle weiter haben sich die
Wälder dadurch erholt von 1984 bis 2017
gab es je nach Baumart gute und
schlechte Jahre Schwankungen mit denen
man bei biologischen Systemen zu rechnen
hat aber der langzeittrennt der
waldzustandsermittlung die mittelt über
alle Baumarten verlief abwärts
1984 waren rund 40 Prozent der Bäume
noch voll belaubt im Jahr 2017 waren es
nur noch 34 Prozent und 2021 nach den
dürrejahren waren es nur noch
21%. inzwischen kennt man viele weitere
Ursachen für den schlechten Zustand der
Welt da bodenas Ozon greift die Blätter
und Nadeln an anhaltende
Extremwetterlagen Schwächen die Bäume
und so haben Krankheiten und Schädlinge
leichtes Spiel auch wie gut die Bäume
genährt sind spielt natürlich eine Rolle
was uns wieder auf die sauren Böden
zurückbringt der saure Regen von damals
steckt nämlich tatsächlich noch heute in
unserem Boden und es kommen immer noch
Schwefel und Stickoxide dazu wenn auch
viel weniger als früher saurer Boden
stellt weniger Kationen insbesondere
Kalzium Magnesium und Kaliumionen zur
Verfügung die für die Bäume aber wichtig
sind deshalb wird über einigen
Waldgebieten vom Hubschrauber aus immer
wieder Kalk gestreut der Kalk
neutralisiert die Säure und macht die
Nährstoffe wieder verfügbar
also was heißt das jetzt in erster Linie
steht fest dass Regulierungen von
Schadstoffemissionen das Waldsterben
gebremst haben ob die ökosterie der 80er
Jahre überzogen war das kann man nicht
wissen aber ich denke ohne die große
Öffentlichkeit für das Thema hätte die
schwarz-gelbe Bundesregierung sicherlich
keine Luftfilter für Industrieanlagen
vorgeschrieben und diese und folgende
Maßnahmen haben so die Experten die uns
bei diesem Video hier fachlich
unterstützt haben das Waldsterben
ausgebremst beendet ist es aber noch
nicht heute ist das Waldsterben so
bedrohlich wie nie zuvor
2021 schrieb der Spiegel erneut der
deutsche Wald stirbt denn die Dürre der
Jahre 2018 bis 2020 hat die
absterberaten der Bäume verfünffacht die
der Fichte hat sich sogar
verzwanzigfacht und wegen des
Klimawandels werden solche dürrjahre in
Zukunft nicht mehr die Ausnahme sondern
die Regel sein
jetzt ist natürlich die Frage wäre es
jemals so schlimm gekommen wie Experten
und Medien gewarnt haben hätten wir
jetzt keinen Wald mehr in Deutschland
wenn es keine Maßnahmen gäbe eine
Antwort darauf gibt es nicht eben weil
die Katastrophe ja verhindert wurde
diesen Umstand nutzen Kritiker der
Maßnahmen natürlich gerne und behaupten
einfach die Maßnahmen sein unnötig
gewesen
there is no glory in prevention es gibt
keinen Ruhm für Prävention das ist das
ernüchternde Fazit bei denjenigen die
die Katastrophe abgewendet haben dabei
ist das Vermeiden eines Problems die
effizienteste und sicherste Lösung in
einer Gefahrensituation leider ist sie
auch ziemlich unspektakulär keine
Zeitung Titel groß hey schaut her es ist
nichts passiert unter den Menschen
breitet sich deshalb der Trugschluss aus
die Probleme hätten sich ganz von
alleine gelöst und die Warnungen die
Angst und die Maßnahmen wären unnötig
gewesen
saurer Regen und Klimawandel gehen beide
unter anderem auf die Verbrennung
fossiler Brennstoffe zurück die
Emissionen von schwefeloxiden
Stickoxiden und kohlenoxiden haben
anhaltende negative Auswirkungen auf
unsere Ökosysteme auf unsere Gesundheit
und auch auf die Wirtschaft und zwar
global entsprechend warnen vor dem
Klimawandel auch nicht nur einige
Forstwissenschaftler und Ökologen
sondern darüber hinaus auch zehntausende
Forscherinnen und Forscher aus allen
relevanten Fachgebieten und nicht nur
hier sondern überall auf der Erde
Unmengen unabhängiger Studien weisen
eine globale Bedrohung durch den
Klimawandel nach und zeigen auf wie man
das Schlimmste noch vermeiden kann aber
während man gegen die Emissionen von
schwefeloxiden und Stickoxiden recht
erfolgreich vorgeht Bremsen dieselben
Parteien die 1983 Filtersysteme für
Industrieanlagen eingeführt haben seit
30 Jahren die Klimaschutzmaßnahmen aus
und das obwohl die düsteren Prognosen
der Wissenschaft immer wieder von der
Realität überholt werden schön wäre es
natürlich wenn die Warnungen zur
Klimakatastrophe in der Zukunft als
übertrieben beobachtet werden könnten
sei es weil es tatsächlich nicht so
schlimm gekommen ist oder weil wir durch
massives Eingreifen die Katastrophe
verhindert haben
wenn wir uns aber die Entwicklung der
CO2-Emissionen und der
extremwetterkatastrophen über die
letzten Jahrzehnte anschauen scheint
weder das eine noch das andere Szenario
einzutreten was wir und ihr tun können
ist im Rahmen unserer Möglichkeiten
dabei zu helfen CO2-Emissionen
einzusparen sieht natürlich für jeden
anders aus aber wir sind alle
gleichermaßen gefragt wenn es um die
Unterstützung von Initiativen und
Aktivisten geht die systemische
Änderungen herbeiführen wollen wir alle
sind gefragt den Druck auf die Politik
zu erhöhen denn die hat in unserer
Gesellschaft den größten Hebel und der
hätte eigentlich schon vor 30 Jahren
gezogen werden müssen beim
Schwefeldioxid hat es ja auch geklappt
es gibt übrigens die Möglichkeit selber
komplett klimaneutral zu leben zwar nur
rein rechnerisch aber das ist ja auch
schon mal ein riesiger Schritt mit der
App Klima könnt ihr eure eigenen
CO2-Emissionen erst berechnen und dann
direkt ausgleichen lassen ihr könnt euch
aber auch Tipps für einen nachhaltigeres
Leben holen oder der Politik in den
Hintern treten indem ihr eurem lokalen
Abgeordneten im Bundestag schreibt dass
er sich für mehr Klimaschutz einsetzen
soll das geht alles direkt und schnell
in der App und ist mega praktisch für
das CO2 auf Setting berechnet die App
auf Basis eure Angaben einen monatlichen
Beitrag der dann in eine Vielzahl an
Umweltschutzprojekten investiert wird
noch besser als CO2 Ausgleich ist aber
insgesamt nachhaltiger zu leben dazu
gibt es eine eigens produzierte
Videoreihe mit hilfreichen Tipps für
eine nachhaltigeren Alltag mit unserem
Code dr Watson werden bei der Anmeldung
direkt zehn Bäume in eurem Namen
gepflanzt und die unterstützt damit auch
noch uns und unsere Videos hier also
geht gerne auf den ersten Link unten in
der Videobeschreibung und installiert
euch die App
wenn ihr euch aber noch nicht so ganz
sicher seid ob die App hält was sie
verspricht dann schaut euch gerne mal
dieses Video hier an da haben wir uns
ganz kritisch mit der klima-app selber
und dem Thema CO2 auf Setting allgemein
auseinandergesetzt auch wenn kein Weg
daran vorbei führt dass wir dringend
strengere Regeln aus der Politik
brauchen halte ich jede Form von
Aktivität und Einsatz gegen den
Klimawandel für sinnvoll deshalb auch
noch mal vielen vielen Dank an euch alle
aus der Doktor Watson Community die sich
die App schon heruntergeladen haben und
jeden Monat CO2-Emissionen offsetten wie
immer vielen Dank fürs zuschauen bleibt
hoffnungsvoll geht auf die Straße euer
Cedric